Yeah.
Alright.
You hear me?
Yeah.
You can hear me?
Oh my god, we're reading an astronomy course, that's my favorite.
Ready?
Can you hear me?
Testing?
One, two, three.
You guys are saying where's mommy but on my end it says I'm streaming.
Where's this new streamer?
Reefling rain.
Get to go?
You hear me?
Okay, let's go.
Literally I did not do a thing.
Hi, thank you for the read.
Strongly cuttles, thank you so much.
I hope you had a good stream.
What did you get up to?
Oh, you're playing LEGO Lord of the Rings.
I am Strongly Cuttles from Vealor, Gen 1.
We do alternative things on the base of our spaces.
Other than that we are pretty much regular, schmagular feature groups that just do their
thing and have a good time.
Thank you so much for the redirect that was very kind of you.
Oh, I see it's a reefling is your fan name.
That's a very cute name.
I wonder where you got it from?
This will be the shortest stream.
Sure.
Literally I think I'll read like a few marshmallows and I'll pass them out and then I'll fix the
thumbnail when I can.
Give me all your money.
Oh my god, we're destroying Hobbits and no, the books are real.
Literally 71% right now.
It's really destroying all of us though.
That shit was blending in.
I can't see none.
If I can get an animal to raise, I don't have to actually.
That's what I think about your corn patch.
You Skellywags.
Should I collab with Strongly?
Do you like her?
I don't know much about her.
I'll need to do my research in case her agency is after her history.
She's destroying everything I possibly can.
Fair warning, she's got all...
You know what I've heard about them Scottish chicks, you know.
The culture clash is out the wazoo.
Not very good, not very good at all.
She's a bit unhinged but she's a nice girl.
I mean, if she means well, that's the main thing.
Even if things don't always work out as long as you mean well at the end of the day, then, you know.
What are you doing?
You remind me a little bit of her.
Would we get along?
If you think we can get along.
I'm not a shy VTuber.
I message people and say, hey, want to collab?
Well, we are 83%.
Not the worst.
Yeah, she loves Lord of the Rings.
Okay, okay, I like anyone who's a friend of Lord of the Rings, a friend of mine.
Like, after destroying their house, they're just chilling out in the open.
They're like, where did all of our housing go?
I could have sworn I paid a mortgage for something.
83%.
84%.
She also makes a lot of bread each stream.
No, she might be brewing it internally.
I can tell you that much, but pass on it, fuck no.
That shit doesn't come out of that whenever I see it.
Where's house?
Literally, where's house gone?
84%.
I mean, I like all these wee things and such.
That is so unfortunate, but I can't even think at one point on stream
where I wasn't super productive in terms of like,
like I was mucking about, like, you know, something.
Like, that's nonstop.
I don't know how on air.
How am I supposed to get up here?
Oh, I can get up here though.
I didn't realize I had access to this.
Oh, there's already a rope.
Sorry.
I'm starting to forget you and mommy look quite similar, huh?
I don't remember this part in talking.
I don't remember either.
I'm gonna rave before I...
I'm very curious to see if this is the last part
and how long the stream actually went on for it
because I have a feeling it's gonna be a millisecond.
It says I've streamed for five minutes
and one minute was me being like, can you hear me? Hello?
Eighty-six percent.
I think this is a replica of Riffin' though.
If you're looking for shorter games in the future,
there's a remake of the robot.
What? I don't know that.
Beat the crap out of these.
Everything.
Give me your money. Eighty-seven percent.
Girl, I'm sweet. I'm extorting.
Oh, why would you jump up?
I'm extorting everything for every last painting.
I can't even reach that. I'm too small.
These are unbreakable. Unbreakable?
Unbreakable?
Unbreakable trees?
This is all unbreakable now.
Sunflower?
Up next, Subscriber to the World in Konghua.
Hit Subscribers against each other.
No, I'm just kidding.
What is this?
Who's it that?
Sure. I'm glad that helps.
This is Lorian, clearly, because of the trees.
We're destroying all of Middle-earth.
Since they couldn't do it, they were unsuccessful.
We're letting them do it in the Lego world.
Oh, wow. A whole 1,000 studs for me?
These levels just lower to the range of sorrow and prep.
I can't even... Is this a joke?
I'm being trolled.
What is this, dude?
Huh?
I didn't expect... I have to admit I didn't expect that.
8.9%? Can I break this down?
You're so...
8%.
I literally couldn't have it.
I need the sheep, because they're so fast.
And dealing with these little things as well.
I'll take them back to that other location.
But, literally, the sheep can skirt the edge so well.
And they can knock little things that I wouldn't necessarily...
Clickbait? Did you fall for it?
The literal last 5 seconds of the darn stream.
You've got pranks!
Oh, I got you so good.
You feel so pranked right now.
I bet you feel like the egg is on your face.
Oh, all that egg on your face?
Yeah.
That's good for me, you're welcome.
Let's...
Break all this.
Seriously, I don't know what developer thought of this level.
They were evil. Pure evil.
90%. Thank you.
We're getting there, we're getting there, we're getting there, we're getting there.
Skirting the edge.
There's a lot of plants.
The plants all add up.
What is Sauron doing to that gun?
He's just in...
You know.
Let's destroy the plants and only give them money.
People don't give money.
No, so stop trying to destroy them.
Pure people are just trying to live after pillage their land.
Take that, that's what I think about your beer.
The one thing here.
Oh my god, I'm such a failure.
Ding ding!
I'm here to pillage.
I didn't do it, I didn't actually...
Okay, okay, okay.
We're still missing 96,000.
96,000.
I need to go back in that cavern, I think.
Sauron is...
We got a bridge.
Going back in this cavern because...
I mean, shit, am I really getting that desperate?
I need to pick up the wee one.
You have to literally get every stud?
I hope that, is that real?
Is that actually real?
I'm not scrimping over silver studs.
No way that's...
There has to be room for mobility.
There's no room.
I refuse to believe that the game literally is like I am.
As if they, I can't jump over that.
Please, work with me here.
I'm just sitting in the back, going back and forth, back and forth.
Yeah.
Go to the ledge if you want to.
The hardest challenge is the lift for the last...
This doesn't move, you don't do anything?
Don't you do?
Don't prank me now.
92%, don't prank me now.
I'm getting there.
I'm getting every last problem in this main, do you understand?
You're in the main chat.
Enough of that.
I can't beat this up.
I can't do that.
I can't claim up there because I'm heavy.
I don't want this to be a troll or something.
I'm also going to destroy this now because I want the head put in remove.
9.2.
This is indestructible or doesn't need to push it or something.
This is pushable.
It's on tracks.
Push it.
I'm not sure why.
Okay.
And now I can destroy it.
Mm-hmm.
I destroy you now?
I serve like glitches out.
Why?
I feel like I should have got the other one.
And before bug.
I don't want to hear it.
Ow.
I don't want to hear such slander.
We're 9.3.
9.3.
There's something behind the fire over here that never touched me.
Ow.
Beat it up.
9.3.
3.
93.
Okay.
I'm going to equip the bombs because the bombs will auto-target.
Sorry, fireworks.
They should auto-target shape.
What shape?
I don't know.
Just anything that might be like that.
For example.
Is this really...
Do I really not do anything at all?
It just moves about.
I can't seem to destroy that.
Okay.
I'm just...
But...
I think I did it.
I don't think the left one went in.
No.
I don't think so either.
I think it glitched out for me unfortunately.
I can't even correct it.
So I'm really hoping this is not the final factor.
And that the game developers were wise enough to not make a mode.
That was so dependent on the destruction of one building alone.
You know?
Maybe I can reach back here.
The back of the roof.
I mean, I'll take a blue stud for my efforts.
I'll do, as I said, a mosh.
Sheep can get me around a lot faster.
So...
What's the dealy over here?
Okay.
I'm on my fireworks.
Maybe.
Uh...
Did I drop much from the fireworks?
Abracadabra.
I don't know.
Okay.
Name point five one...
Name five point one percent.
Sorry, I keep saying it wrong for them.
I'm a bit...
I swear.
Alright, Loth Lorian.
I'm gonna need you to Loth offer me some money.
How about that?
Okay, that's more like it.
Okay, that makes a bit more sense.
Nope.
Okay, so we can climb up the tree.
Whack what we can.
Okay.
There we go.
Lord of the Rings, complete the bonus level.
Unlock all characters.
There and back again.
Get a hundred percent.
We did it.
And we did it.
Yeah, thanks for the million studs,
as if my, like, a billion, like, things don't counter that.
But we did it.
Hundred percent.
Lord of the Rings.
Only took me three streams.
I'm kicking my butt so badly right now
that I didn't do at least a few things
before I finished this stream.
I didn't think.
Lutz newborn.
I knew there was something to do with Lutz.
A little sheet bag.
We did it.
That's done.
Play the field.
Play that faded field.
Hold on, where is it?
Oh, no way.
Thank you so much for the gifts and memberships.
I thought, okay, thank you.
Holy crap.
Congrats to those who caught it with your face.
Thank you so much.
We did it.
Hundred percent.
Complete though.
Squishy.
Thank you for the extended membership as well.
Congrats, Johnny.
Thank you.
Let's go, Lutz.
A short day.
A red day.
Bill shall be shaken.
Bill shall be flitters.
Bye now.
Bye, far away.
Shroom.
Baa.
Are you squidding me right now?
What?
Nameless. Thank you for the 10 gifted memberships. It says anonymous. It says
nameless on the other screen. Thank you for the 10 gifted memberships as well.
Thank you. I didn't know where that hate for Legal Lord of the Rings got aim.
Thank you. So very kind. Thank you again. I honestly thought you were trawlin. I'm
not gonna lie. Not to do you. Not Doro, but yeah.
Gamer sub's yum. Use 10% Shawnee for 10% off. Shit. I don't know what I'm talking about, I believe.
Thank y'all. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank y'all.
Smuggot? Did you just change your name in real-time? Did that work?
It says smuggot.
Yo, Samwise is hitting it. Look at him going with that pan.
Ay, ay, ay, ay.
God damn.
Release, leather.
Quickest Gamer sub partnership to my face.
Wasn't there an ending cutscene? Not that I know of.
Oh, In the Shire?
Buster the Roe, hear him, hear him.
Oh my god, Iron Reapers as well. Thank you for the 50 gifted membership.
Guys, what the fuck?
There's a final cutscene. Where did I get it? Thank you, Iron Reapers.
Thank you, Smuggot is what it says. I don't know.
Smuggot.
Do more. Thank you, Will.
And Pakufo again. Holy crap.
Thank you so much for all the kindness. Holy crap.
Please do thank if you catch us up.
Don't worry if you don't know us right away though.
Talk to Bilbo in the final cutscene.
Okay.
Oh my god. Will I do the same tenors?
Well, thank you everyone so much.
What the fuck? There's not gonna be one green aim in the house.
Oh my gosh. Are we ready for the cutscene?
Holy gifted, literally. Thank you for what you've been saying.
Thank you, Iron Reapers. Thank you, Smuggot.
And thank you, Pakufo.
Yeah, meep. So many gifted. So many people dodging it as well.
I have to admit it's a little bit funny.
Okay, ready for the last cutscene?
Are you ready?
I broke.
My game crashed.
Okay, hold on a minute. Hold on a minute. My game crashed.
Hold on. Let's try that again. Hold on.
I broke my freaking...
Hold on. Hold on. What a cutscene.
No, no, it's fine. It's fine. Hold on. Let me just...
Oh, I didn't even realise I was cut off randomly.
Why am I cut off? Why am I cut off?
I didn't change anything about me.
Why am I floating?
Sorry, man. Let's try that again. Hold on. Hold on.
Hold on. Let me do the cutscene.
Let me do the cutscene.
Okay, it's opening up. I'm pausing. Probably I'm starting about.
Hold on. Let's try again, okay?
I'm in the cutscene.
I swear if that registered that I can't rewatch the cutscene, I'm gonna cry.
Okay, let's try that again.
Load game. 100%.
Let's go to Hobbiton.
Really? Yeah, you really enjoyed that.
Let's hope this cutscene doesn't break my game.
And it's still accessible.
Okay.
Let's make our way to Hobbiton.
Okay, let's try that again, shall we?
Okay, captain's lost the noodles. Thank you for becoming a member.
Right, cutscene.
No memory leakage.
I will enjoy it for what it's worth, okay?
Shit!
It's corrupt.
My game files corrupt. I can't play the scene.
I broke my thing again.
My files corrupt after 100%.
Do you want a third time? Do we try a third time?
It's corrupt. I don't know.
I don't know.
Time to open a video.
Oh my god.
I think I'm gonna have to...
Lego, Lord of the Rings, ending 100% cutscene.
And then I'll share screen.
Okay, this is 100% my gameplay.
What you're about to see, okay?
This is 100% my gameplay.
100%, no doubt this is my gameplay.
This is my gameplay.
This is...
Hold on.
You went a bit fast for me and we'll be honest.
We can't expect me to do that so quickly.
Fucking hell.
How about you just relax for one day?
Just bring yourself down a little bit.
Hold on.
This is still my gameplay.
What do you mean you can see the pause?
What are you talking about?
Fucking hell. How many things have I got instant?
See? It's 100% my gameplay.
Are we ready to play it?
You ready?
What do you mean YouTube isn't a full...
No, YouTube isn't full screen. What are you talking about?
10 billion stu...
Yeah.
The game crashed and it gave me some of the studs that I owed me.
Okay, 100% my gameplay.
Okay, let's see what this is all about.
Button number three.
Oh, it crashed. No.
The age of elves is over.
The age of now.
I think I'm...
one ready for another break.
I think so, yeah.
I ain't crying over legal blocks today.
I'll cry in the movie though.
No.
Great note.
Aww, they brought the gang in.
Borrow me, I've just been chilling as I go.
Thank you for coming to member in the Directed Tour.
They did it!
Yatta!
Oh my god, we did it.
I don't know why my file's corrupted and couldn't play that.
As if my PC isn't an absolute beast.
Please relax, PC.
Please relax.
But we're here, we did it!
We did it!
Do you want Marshmallow or are we all going to sleep?
Because we're exhausted.
Well, speaking of really hard Dark Souls games,
I guess I'm redirecting into it.
You didn't hear that.
You didn't hear who I'm redirecting into.
If you recognised who that was via a squeal.
One, you're cooked.
Two, that's amazing.
Please, you need to get a shower at to do it.
I'm sweating and disgusting.
I can feel my...
I can feel everything.
Uh...
Uh, right.
Oh, thank you, Odin.
Yeah, could you?
We're becoming a member as well.
Holy shit, that was insane.
Thank you again for all the gifted memberships.
I didn't expect any of that.
Nor did you have to do that, but that was incredibly kind of you.
That was insanity, incarnate.
That was crazy.
She's redirecting into Mercium.
Wait, is it Mercium?
Mercie's not online right now.
She's not live, you stinker.
She's not like...
Tron, which kind of is.
Okay, thank you.
Shout out to the save file for being corrupted.
Um...
Thank you so, so much everyone
for just being so lovely.
I'm gonna be redirecting to someone.
I'll stay for a moment and then I'm out.
I need to go lie down and get a shower
and then lie down because I fucking stink.
Literally, um, thank you.
There's not even a point of being like, haha, pheromone...
No, I literally weak. I'm disgusting.
I'm filthy. I need to scrub my skin.
The grease on me is enough to open up
a fish and chip shop on my head alone.
As much as I like to meme about
I need a shower, okay?
So don't encourage the pheromone max on the other point.
Thank you so, so much for the love and the support
and just the craziness that is
that I get to share, like, these silly games
that I absolutely adore
and just you guys tolerating it all
and listening to me blab and constantly and all that.
Thank you so, so much.
I will see you giffy givers tomorrow.
Tomorrow's a walk shorter and you have four hours
of me tomorrow or something like that.
I can't recall but we'll know, we'll know.
Thank you so, so much.
I give you, oh wait, I give you
big...
Oh wait, why am I cut off at the top?
I think the game like broke my configuration
somehow.
Big kiss.
And as always when I redirect
into others, please
that
I
everyone's different when I redirect.
Okay.
Bye.
Bye bye.